Mysteries of Vernacular.
Pants: An item of clothing that covers the body from the waist to the ankles or knees,...
...each leg having a separate tubular piece.
We also know them as trousers.
The history of the word "pants" begins in the 4th century with the Roman Catholic saint, Pantaleon.
Because Pantaleon was the patron saint of Venice, Venetians were commonly called "Pantaleonis."
In 16th century Italy, a type of comedy theater called commedia dell'arte was born.
The masked characters of the theater were based on stock types...
...like the comic servant Harlequin, the clown Scaramouch and the miserly Venetian merchant Pantalone.
The Venetian trader's costume was distinguished by the particular cut of his trousers...
...which the French began to call "pantaloons."
By the late 1700s, the word "pantaloons" had come to describe any style of trousers.
As the word migrated to Britain, the lower classes shortened "pantaloons" to "pants."
Though the upper class initially considered the abbreviation vulgar,...
...by the time Edgar Allan Poe printed the word in 1840,...
..."pants" was a generally accepted term with the meaning we know today.